oh yes yeah you can't do it it's like a
little demon on my shoulder hey guys i'm
abby sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen so
as you know I love my food honestly I
can't really think of anything I don't
love I'll eat pretty much everything and
I have traveled thousands of miles
exclusively just to eat it's literally
my livelihood so when I became pregnant
I found out there are a lot of foods
that are on the nono list for the baby
and I mean I'm excited to be a mom and
all but kind of put a damper on things
with this whole pregnancy so with just a
few more weeks to go before I evict this
child I am so excited to get into these
10 foods oh my god I cannot wait and as
always ladies be sure to speak to your
doctor about the risks and benefits of
consuming a variety of foods during
pregnancy so you can determine the best
diet for you now let's get to the list
[Music]
number one brie cheese oh my god I
cannot wait an obsessed with cheese and
Brie is my all-time favorite so we hear
all the time that unpasteurized cheeses
are a bit dangerous for pregnant women
but brie cheese even the pasteurized
version has a lower acidity content and
a higher moisture content which makes it
more susceptible to bacterial growth so
that makes it a no-no for us expectant
mamas oh but in just a few more sweet
weeks I am going to be swimming in the
Brie and I cannot wait number two
chamomile tea mmm this used to be a
daily staple for me and it might seem
like a really great option if you're
trying to cut back on caffeine while
you're pregnant or if you're just really
stressed out and anxious about the
thought of pushing a watermelon out of
your vajayjay and cow mouse seems to be
super soothing however there are some
potential risks so the thing about
herbal teas is for the most part we
don't have a whole lot of research on
them during pregnancy or whether or not
they're safe during pregnancy but what
we do know about Kim Maui is it's
thought that it may increase the risk of
uterine contractions which may put you
at risk of preterm labor so the reality
is it's probably not going to put you in
labor at like 10 weeks pregnant after
just having a cup of chamomile tea
however just to play it safe I've
decided to cut it out number three
coffee hmm I need this so badly right
now my baby brain is a problem and I am
not sleeping well so the thought of
waking up and having like a couple cups
of coffee maybe two three four right I
don't know seems like a really great
idea but I've been really careful to
limit my caffeine intake to between 200
and 300 milligrams a day maximum because
an excessive amount of caffeine has been
linked to a risk of miscarriage it's
kind of sucked I'm not gonna lie to have
to track it but I'm really looking
forward to being free with my caffeine
post baby number 4 cookie dough ice
cream
whoa this is one of my favorite flavors
of all times and it's killed me not to
indulge but here's the thing homemade
ice cream tends to be made with
undercooked eggs in the actual custard
base and cookie dough ice cream
specifically is made with raw eggs in
the cookie dough so there's definitely a
risk of Salmonella that you don't want
to put your baby at risk for it's gonna
be hard but the second this baby comes
out we are going for a walk and I'm
gonna get myself a double scoop
number five charcuterie there is nothing
like a good charcuterie board and it is
made going to dinner parties miserable
because let's be real isn't that why we
go to these parties for the appetizers
honestly but here's the thing all of
these kinds of cured meats or deli meats
or pates do put you at higher risk of
contracting Listeria and they say yes
you can eat it if you've cooked it to
steaming but how the hell are you going
to waste a beautiful platter of cured
meats by putting it in the steamer no no
I am super excited to have a beautiful
shook three plate the second this baby
comes out it better be waiting for me in
the delivery room nurses take note
number six jerky oh my god
this is like one of my favorite snacks
of all time it has killed me not to
indulge on the regular but here's the
thing jerky is cooked at the too low
temperature over a long period of time
so it does increase the risk of
bacterial contamination and that really
really sucks but after baby I'm gonna be
getting my jerky on I'm gonna jerk off
to this jerky and I cannot wait you can
do whatever you want with that number
seven
kombucha now we know kombucha is so good
for gut health because it's packed with
probiotics and I love using it both in
my float recipe and to make delicious
lower calorie cocktails but because it's
unpasteurized there is a risk of
Listeria so I've kind of had to put it
on the back burner for these past nine
months
super excited to get my kombucha on
mm-hmm Oh number eight
runny eggs now during my pregnancy I was
able to capture some serious yolk porn
however I wasn't actually able to enjoy
it post shoot because of the risk of
salmonella from the raw eggs so I am
definitely in need of some Betty's to
fill the void after baby number nine
tiramisu Oh for a private woman tiramisu
is basically a triple threat because
it's got raw eggs coffee and liqueur in
it so I've definitely tried to stay away
but look at it just look at it how can
you deny yourself this goodness when
you're pregnant it's torture but as soon
as this baby comes out I am going on an
official tiramisu crawl so guys if you
love some tiramisu tell me where to get
the goods cuz I cannot wait to dig in
and number ten mmm wine my beloved wine
I've saved the best for last and the
thing that I'm craving the most
post-baby because let's be real what's a
life without wine especially as a mother
so from white to red to sparkling to box
I don't discriminate I'm willing to take
anything at this point but of course
during these nine months I have
refrained because of the risk of fetal
alcohol syndrome but let me tell ya once
this baby's out I'm going straight for
the bottle smells good guys smells
really good well this whole episode has
been absolute torture I hope you enjoy
watching me go through it well if you
did be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below if you're a mom
or a mom to be what food would you miss
or did you miss during your pregnancy
also subscribe to the channel and I will
see you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]